y cómo volver a asentarse en sus antiguas áreas de nidificación
y de alimentación.
Había algunos conservacionistas,
muy famosos, como Stanley Temple,
que es uno de los fundadores de la biología conservacionista,
y Kate Jones de UICN, que publica la Lista Roja.
Están muy entusiasmados con todo esto,
pero también están preocupados de que pueda entrar en competencia
con los enormes esfuerzos para proteger
especies en peligro de extinción que aún están vivas,
y que todavía no se han extinguido.
Verán, se quiere trabajar en proteger los animales que existen.
Se quiere trabajar en bajar la demanda de marfil en el mercado asiático,
para no matar 25 000 elefantes al año.
Pero al mismo tiempo, los biólogos conservacionistas notan
que las malas noticias deprimen a la gente.
Así que la Lista Roja es muy importante, para llevar registro
de qué está en peligro de extinción y en peligro crítico de extinción, etc.
Pero están por crear lo que llaman una Lista Verde,
y la Lista Verde, enumerará a las especies que están bien, gracias,
especies que solían estar en peligro de extinción, como el águila calva,
pero que ahora están mucho mejor, gracias al buen trabajo de todos,
y a las áreas de protección de todo el mundo
que están muy, muy bien dirigidas.
Así que básicamente, están aprendiendo a redactar buenas noticias.
Y ven que revivir especies extintas
es el tipo de buena noticia a partir de la que se puede construir.
Les doy un par de ejemplos relacionados.
La crianza en cautiverio será una parte importante de traer a la vida a estas especies.
El cóndor de California se vio reducido a 22 aves en 1987.
Todos pensaron que estaba acabado.
Gracias a la crianza en cautiverio en el Zoológico de San Diego,
actualmente hay 405 de ellos, 226 están en su hábitat natural.
Esa tecnología será utilizada con los animales de-extintos.
Otra historia exitosa es la del gorila de montaña en África Central.
En 1981, Dian Fossey estaba segura de que se extinguirían.
Quedaban tan solo 254 ejemplares.
Hoy hay 880. Y su población aumenta
un 3% por año.
El secreto es que tienen un programa de eco turismo,
que es absolutamente brillante.
Esta fotografía la tomó Ryan el mes pasado
con un iPhone.
Así de cómodos se sienten estos gorilas salvajes con los visitantes.
Otro proyecto interesante, aunque necesitará algo de ayuda,
es el del rinoceronte blanco del norte.
No quedan pares de reproducción.
Pero esta es la clase de situaciones para las cuales
existe una gran variedad de ADN disponible en el zoo congelado.
Un poco de clonación y se les puede traer de vuelta.
Ahora, ¿cuál es el siguiente paso?
Estas han sido conferencias privadas hasta ahora.
Creo que es hora de que el tema se haga público.
¿Qué piensa la gente al respecto?
Ya saben, ¿quieren que vuelvan las especies extintas?
¿Quieren que vuelvan las especies extintas?
(Aplausos)
Campanita vendrá volando ahora.
Es un momento para Campanita,
porque, ¿qué es lo que entusiasma a la gente de este tema?
¿Qué les preocupa?
Vamos a seguir adelante con la paloma migratoria.
Así que Ben Novak, en este momento, está sumándose al grupo
que Beth Shapiro tiene en UC Santa Cruz.
Van a trabajar en el genoma
de la paloma migratoria y la paloma de collar.
A medida que esta información crezca, se la enviarán a George Church,
quien operará su magia, y de eso, sacará ADN de paloma migratoria.
Obtendremos la ayuda de Bob Lanza y Mike McGraw
para introducir el plasma germinal en gallinas
para que reproduzcan polluelos de paloma migratoria,
que puedan ser criados por padres palomas de collar,
y a partir de este momento, serán palomas migratorias para siempre,
quizás durante los próximos seis millones de años.
Ustedes pueden hacer lo mismo, a medida que bajen los costes,
por la cotorra de Carolina, el alca gigante,
por el urogallo grande, el carpintero real,
por el zarapito esquimal, la foca monje del Caribe,
y por el mamut lanudo.
Porque el hecho es que, los humanos hemos creado un enorme agujero
en la naturaleza, durante los últimos 10 000 años.
Hoy tenemos la capacidad,
y quizá la obligación moral, de reparar un poco del daño.
Mucho de esto lo lograremos expandiendo y protegiendo las tierras salvajes,
expandiendo y protegiendo
las poblaciones de especies en peligro de extinción.
Pero a algunas especies
que hemos matado por completo
podríamos considerar traerlas a la vida nuevamente
a un mundo que las echa de menos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Chris Anderson: Gracias.
Tengo una pregunta.
Este es un tema emotivo. Algunos están de pie.
Sospecho que debe de haber algunos sentados en la audiencia
atormentándose con preguntas del estilo:
bien, espera, espera, espera, espera un minuto,
hay algo que está muy mal si la humanidad
interfiere con la naturaleza de esta forma.
Va a haber consecuencias no intencionadas.
Se va a abrir una especie de Caja de Pandora
de quién sabe qué. ¿Tienen algo de razón?
Stewart Brand: Bien, el primer punto es que
interferimos muchísimo cuando hicimos que estos animales se extinguieran,
y muchos eran especies claves,
y cambiamos todo el ecosistema del que eran parte
cuando los dejamos ir.
Ahora, tenemos el problema de los puntos de referencia cambiantes, que es
que cuando estas especies regresen,
pueden llegar a reemplazar algunas aves que
las personas ya conocen y aman.
Y creo que eso, ya saben, es parte de como sucederá.
Este es un proceso largo y lento a la vez.
Una de las cosas que me gustan de esto es que es multigeneracional.
Traeremos de vuelta a los mamuts lanudos.
CA: Bien, pare que tanto la conversación,
como el potencial aquí, son muy emocionantes.
Muchísimas gracias por la presentación. SB: Gracias.
CA: Gracias. (Aplausos)